l'ambiance de rassemblement n'était pas
festive mais plutôt entre 24 et le 7
juillet s'ils battent commémorative pour
soi disant n'être dépendance de
l'algérie
mais dans le fond on n'est pas libérée
ne peut pas libérer leur irak le
mouvement de protestation populaire qui
a éclaté à 16 mois en algérie se
poursuit malgré le changement à la tête
du pays survenue en décembre puisque
selon les manifestants le nouveau
président abdelmadjid t bone n'est que
l'héritier du régime précédent
le droit à la santé le droit au sua à
l'éducation le droit de décider de son
avenir il est vraiment mitigée c'est pas
le cas
la mobilisation citoyenne a plus semblé
s'essouffler depuis l'instauration de
l'état d'urgence mis en place en algérie
en raison de la pandémie que 8,19 mais
ce n'est qu'une impression selon ce
membre de la communauté
donc c'est pour dire que cette
révolution ait n'est pas morte avec les
pros vite donc on évite le monde à l'eau
se tenir à paris aussi des membres de la
diaspora ont manifesté en soutien au cac
et le discours est semblable
le peuple algérien veut avoir
complètement
il veut avoir un état démocratique
a alger les restes de 24 combattants
apci coloniaux tués lors de la guerre
d'algérie restitués par la france ont
été enterré lors d'une cérémonie
officielle à laquelle le président
algérien a assisté le président est
bonne a salué le geste de la france
mais il demande à l'ancienne puissance
coloniale d'aller plus loin dans ses
excuses
pour certains membres de la diaspora
algérienne à montréal cette cérémonie
n'est qu'une opération médiatique du
pouvoir en place pour ces victimes et un
geste symbolique qui n'a aucun effet sur
la situation politique actuelle et si
fanny bussières mechanical radio canada
montréal